you've been a bad boy Lloyd you ate the
forbidden fruit now you shall be cast
into the valley of unemployment by by
harsher grace I want this to hurt him
personally
boy you got greedy with the
pizzas fired alright we're getting
somewhere
should we reward ourselves to justice
being served
some people are weak and I say let him
die are you choking
I don't know CPR I'm gonna google it the
Wi-Fi is being shitty I'm just gonna
film this
[Music]
take don't make that face
I need
even crossed my mind you gotta be
careful with those pinkies I get it
though they're the best ones take it
easy
[Music]
it's not CPR so Heimlich oh yeah I don't
know how to do that one either
[Music]